- Artificial intelligence.
- Jobs.
- Job.
- Artificial intelligence.
- [Joanna] You've heard the AI warnings.
- Every technological revolution
affects the job market.
- AI could cost some humans
their jobs in the near future.
- But AI is also creating some
new jobs, specifically one.
So I decided to apply.
Job title: prompt engineer.
Responsibilities: writing text commands
or prompts to get the best answers out
of a generative AI large
language model like ChatGPT.
Pay: up to $250,000 a year.
To figure out exactly what
a prompt engineer does,
I decided to apply to be one at Hebbia,
a New York-based AI startup.
Wish me luck.
Hi
- Swetha. Good to meet you.
- Nice to meet.
- Welcome to the office.
- I have wanted to be a prompt engineer
as long as I can remember.
(rewinding sound)
All right, fine, the company was in
on this little experiment.
- It's really interesting
that you say that
because the role actually didn't exist
until maybe a year ago.
- [Joanna] Yes, prompt engineering
is a totally new type of job
because well, large language models
or LLMs, like ChatGPT only
hit the scene a year ago.
And if you've used ChatGPT,
prompt engineering is actually
pretty easy to understand.
You type in your prompt,
instructing whatever you'd like
the large language model to do.
The model then returns an answer,
but sometimes that answer is unwieldy
or not what you wanted.
The better the input,
the better the output.
- For really one of the first times ever,
we've been able to expose
a pretty complicated piece
of technology to someone
that doesn't know how to code,
to someone that knows how
to talk to these models
in a highly instructive, highly clear way.
And that person is the prompt engineer.
- So really it's a translator.
- That's exactly what it is.
You're translating between
the machine and the human.
- Seems like something I
could be pretty good at.
- I think so too.
- But what's a good prompt
and how do you learn to write them?
Well, I went back to school and by school,
I mean a Coursera class.
(playful music)
Look at that. 100 and 100.
- Prompts aren't just a one-off
that you give to the large language model.
- In his six-week prompt
engineering for ChatGPT class,
Dr. Jules White, a professor
of computer science at
Vanderbilt University teaches you
how to structure sentences
to get the desired output from the bot.
You seem bored by this, Browser.
There's the persona or role prompt.
For instance, act as an assistant
helping a financial analyst.
You're instructing the
LLM to take on a persona.
There's the new information prompt.
This is where you feed the model new data
it might not know about.
Say, here's the transcript from
the Microsoft earnings call.
Please summarize the mentions of Bing,
and you get a summary.
Hebbia's Matrix app
actually does all of this.
It allows financial institutions
and other businesses to upload
or access huge datasets, filings,
earnings transcripts, calls.
Then it uses AI to find
answers so people don't have
to manually go through it all.
And that's what Swetha gave me
as a prompt engineering assignment.
- So in this case, let's say
that you are doing an analysis
on earnings calls for a public company.
- I did a pretty good job
at writing those prompts,
but there was another part
of the job I wasn't prepared for: coding.
In some cases, a prompt engineer may have
to code the queries into the tool itself
so Hebbia's clients can
use them with a single tap.
It was about that time
that I knew this probably
wasn't my next job.
Plus, I was a little worried
about how long this job might
be a job, which I decided
to bring up in my interview with the CEO.
Joanna. Nice to meet you.
As these models get better,
is prompt engineering gonna be necessary?
- At the end of the day,
you'll still need people
to tell them explicit instructions.
Even in programming
where machines are perfect
at understanding code,
there's still a job for
people to go back and forth.
- So what did I learn today?
Well, getting a job
as a prompt engineer is
harder than I thought.
Still, anyone who wants to
successfully work with AI tools
and elicit the best answers from them
really should learn some of
these prompt writing skills,
even if your next job title
isn't officially prompt engineer.
(Joanna sighing)
Joanna, enjoyed meeting you too.
After some deliberation,
we will not be continuing
the hiring process here.
Wishing you the best in your search.
Yeah, rough.